join us join us mightiest heroes not
today sir are you making your voice
deeper no fun April 27 summer begins be
mocking me he's trying to copy me
Avengers infinity war - pg-13 Stassi
strange I am spider-man let's go alright
kid
your adventure Aventis you people I saw
maybe you know cut it omits you know
every book zoom it's come we have what
Dennis wants so that's what we is Ethan
et will the entire time I knew him he
only ever had one call
to wipe out half the universe if he gets
all the Infinity stones she can do it
with the snap of his fingers just like
that tell me his name again
danos
[Music]
we got one advantage
he's coming to us
we have a dance once so that's what we
use
[Music]
let's talk about this plan tears I think
it's good except it sucks so let me do
the plan and that way it might be really
good Wow
the end is near
and um
[Music]
half of humanity will still exist
perfectly balanced
this whole thing should be
I hope to remember you
[Music]
I'm Peter by the way dr. strange Oh
using your made-up names then I am
spider-man
[Music]